[Music]
Dmitri Ivanovich Mendeleev played quite
a legendary role in the field of
chemistry he not only gave us the
simplest and the most efficient method
of grouping elements but also laid the
foundations of periodic classification
of elements that we used today so in
this video let's dedicate some time to
understand what and how Mendeleev
actually worked on when Mendeleev began
his work of grouping the elements and
arranging them there were almost 63
elements known to him he was firm on the
thought of arranging the elements with
respect to their physical as well as
chemical properties he knew that for
understanding the chemical properties he
would need to make them react with one
or two standard elements for this
he chose hydrogen and oxygen but why
Mendeleev thought of making the elements
react with hydrogen and oxygen because
of the following reasons
they are very reactive they are found
readily and they form compounds with
most of the elements yes this helped him
understand the chemical properties of
all the reacting elements later in order
to simplify the process he wrote all the
physical and chemical properties of each
element on 63 different cards now all he
had to do is arrange these cards but
that wasn't so simple so he started
arranging the cards in the increasing
order of the atomic masses when he was
done pasting all these cards on his wall
he had two astonishing observations one
was that there were a few empty spaces
left in the complete table that he
formed these positions belong to the
elements that would not yet discovered
but Mendeleev had a firm belief that the
missing elements did exist and are yet
to be discovered not only this but he
was so confident about the
characteristics of these elements that
he predicted their properties well in
advance later on when the elements were
discovered it was found that the
property is predicted by Mendeleev for
almost a
perfect match second observation that
Mendeleev had was the recurrence of the
physical and chemical properties of
these elements when arranged in a
systematic manner it was found that the
physical and chemical properties of
elements record at a particular interval
of frequency with this Mendeleev came up
with a law he named it as the periodic
law the law stated that properties of
elements are periodic functions of the
atomic masses now what do we exactly
mean by this let's simplify this by
breaking the statement in parts
properties of elements means the
physical and chemical properties of all
the elements in the table are the
periodic functions means those which
occur at regular intervals and lastly of
the atomic masses means when arranged in
the increasing order of the atomic
masses so can we simply say that when
elements are arranged in the increasing
order of the atomic masses they show
similarities in the physical and
chemical properties at regular intervals
yes that's what Mendeleev meant this is
how Mendeleev let the foundations for
the modern periodic table but did this
great contribution by Mendeleev have no
limitations at all well there were a few
that emerged with time let's discuss the
achievements and the limitations of
Mendeleev's work in the next video
[Music]
you